da sich fortsetzung folgt es gibt doch
vielen wieder eine fortsetzung dieses
wunder
und das ist es eine geschichte es ist
schicht vor der nikolaus und von der
michaela manser wenn die beiden jungen
frauen im job fehlen warten auf das
zweite leben kennengelernt
die beiden verbindet das gemeinsame
schicksal beide buchen eines
spenderorgans noch eine vitale
abonnieren auch eine säge nur
rechtzeitig eis findet doka tor in
berlin das saarland hat die beiden
jungen frauen vor fünf jahren begleitet
auf ihrem weg zwischen angst und
hoffnung
es ist ein mittwochmittag im winter 2010
schulfrei
aber michaela manser fährt nicht nach
hause sondern ins spital
seit geburt leidet die 20-jährige an
zystischer fibrose kurz c fcf ist eine
stoffwechselkrankheit die normale
funktion der organe ist stark
eingeschränkt vor allem in der lunge
bildet sich zäher schleim
dies führt zu entzündungen und starkem
husten
über die jahre hat sich der schleim ab
das gewebe vernarbt die lunge wird
fortlaufend zerstört regelmäßig muss
michaela manser testen wie
leistungsfähig ihre lunge noch ist jürg
barben vom kinderspital st gallen seit
gut acht jahren betreut er michaela
manser fast 80 prozent ihrer lunge sind
bereits zerstört
normalerweise funktion folgt der masse
menschen auf die und kurve wird ein so
durchlaufen und so stufe also die
schwarze linie wo der vorgeschichte zu
schnuppern
bitte michaela das ist nur natürlich
liegt der bmi stufe und tech lead in
rohstoffe der große teil wo man da
fehlte einfach der luft zum schnuppern
im täglichen dass ich bei der grenze vom
machbaren warum es täglich von hamburg
gewählt
sie macht das hervor
als michaela manser geboren wurde hätte
man nicht gedacht dass sie überhaupt 18
jahre alt wird verschiedene therapien
haben die lebenserwartung von cf
patienten massiv
der herr worten sieht dagegen
politisches phänomen also ich war
ziemlich rollstuhl ist noch ausmacht und
englisch praktisches know-how / mit so
wenig lungenkapazität dass wir so
langsam immer besser wissen bislang
haben ist mein körper gewöhnte immer
noch nie wenn ich weniger weniger
rohstoffe für michaela manser wird es
eng
der atem knapp so wird sie nicht mehr
lange leben können
die entscheidung ob sie eine
lungentransplantation will oder nicht
sollte sie nicht so lange hinauszögern
um auf der warteliste schon warten
warten warten warten warten bis man sie
gerade darum je früheren durch gerichte
bist desto besser kreis bad kreuznach
aber ich darf das körper braucht macht
[Musik]
nur noch selten geht nicola häuser in
den stall es ist zu anstrengend
man sieht es ihr nicht an aber sie
leidet unter einer massiven herzschwäche
es gibt tage da maxi kaum mehr ein paar
schritte gehen weiter
vor neun jahren fingen die probleme an
eine herzoperation hat nicola häuser
bereits hinter sich
aber das herz wird schwächer und
schwächer
ja mein gehirn würde sie jetzt aufs
pferd steigen aber dafür reicht die
kraft nicht der sport war immer mein
leben ich sag jetzt mal wenn ich wenn
das im glücklichsten fall dann noch
wieder möglich ist dass ich wieder ein
pferd reiten kann welche natürlich
überglücklich das wäre der absolute also
dass wer ostern und weihnachten zusammen
das irgendwie schön also aber das ist
sicher nicht das wichtigste
das wichtigste ist eigentlich dass ich
mal wieder ein normales leben führen
kann so ist es denn manchmal auch hart
in den stall zu kommen das pferd zu
sehen macht mich schon traurig wenn man
hat mit erziehung und das ist irgendwie
so herz von hart dabei lief alles so gut
vor 13 jahren kann die profireiterin aus
deutschland in die schweiz feierte
erfolge als lügnerin und holte profilen
und wettkämpfen ein titel an einer
weltmeisterschaft oder an olympischen
spielen alles live im bereich des
möglichen
[Musik]
die kräfte lassen weiter nach es bleibt
nur noch eine möglichkeit nicola heißer
braucht ein neues herz sie ist auf der
warteliste
zusammen mit ihrer sechsjährigen tochter
ana paula lebt nicola heißer in bern
seit drei jahren ist sie von ihrem mann
getrennt
es ist der zwölfte juli 2010
nicola heißer verliert ihren 39
geburtstag
es ist anders als sonst schwester und
mutter sind eigens aus deutschland
angereist
[Musik]
immerhin ja längst bestimmt das kranke
herz den rhythmus und dieser ist für
nicola heißer in den letzten jahren
immer langsamer geworden
die müdigkeit ist manchmal überwältigend
wieder sind ein paar wochen vergangen
seit vier monaten wartet nicola heißer
auf ein neues herz seit vier monaten
trägt sie einen piepser bei sich so dass
sie immer und überall erreichbar ist
innerhalb von zwei stunden muss sie im
inselspital sein können die kontrollen
sind einmalig alle zwei wochen geht sie
zur untersuchung paul moratti ist leiter
des bereichs herzinsuffizienz und
herztransplantation am berner
inselspital immer wieder bespricht er
mit nicola heißer das prozedere und die
operation natürlich relativ rasch
informieren können
das ist sofort die wartezeit das
bedeutet ungewissheit angst und hoffnung
wer auf ein organ wartet muss sich mit
dem tod auseinandersetzen und wünscht
sich nichts mehr als das leben
manchmal sind die wartezeiten lang
monate oder jahre immer ist die angst da
dass die kraft nicht reicht bis man an
der reihe ist bis man endlich oben auf
der liste steht
in der schweiz dürfen organe nur mit
ausdrücklicher zustimmung entnommen
werden
die zuteilung ist gesetzlich genau
geregelt
patienten die in akuter lebensgefahr
schweben gehen vor
sonst soll das spenderorgan dorthin wo
es am besten hinpasst alter und gewicht
zum beispiel sollten nicht zu weit
auseinander liegen
2010 konnten die ärzte bei 98 menschen
organe entnehmen und diese an 504
patienten weitergeben
insgesamt aber haben 1700 menschen auf
ein organ gewartet 59 starben weil das
für sie kein spenderorgan gab
im europäischen vergleich liegt die
schweiz mit den spenderzahlen weit
hinten
weshalb diese zurückhaltung
was geben wir wenn wir ein organ spenden
ist es ein muskel ein bisschen gewebe
oder ein teil unserer persönlichkeit
in ein paar monaten wird michaela manser
die matura machen
heute präsentiert sie ihre maturarbeit
sie wollte er sich mit einem thema
auseinandersetzen dass ihr persönlich
auch etwas bringt also schrieb sie über
das thema lungentransplantation
die präsentation an der kantonsschule
wil ist öffentlich es kommen
schulkollegen freunde die familie und
die eltern sehr viel zeit investiert um
mit physio zu machen
trotz diesen sachen hatte ich eine sehr
schöne kindheit ohne viele probleme
dann als ich zwölf muss das zum ersten
mal in den spital weil ich sehr krank
war
aber ich konnte mir relativ gut erholen
ich bin nicht ein mensch der in der ecke
sitzt und über mein schicksal nachdenkt
und denkt wieso hat es nicht getroffen
das ganze habe ich etwas ins mal ist
dargestellt der größte ist einfach eine
smiley wales leben trotz allem sehr sehr
schön ist und warum ist das leben auch
mit humor nehmen
natürlich gibt es auch traurige momente
oder moment in dem man einfach erschöpft
ist
aber dann habe ich gute freunde die mich
auffangen
vielen dank fürs zuhören und für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das warten für nicola heißer geht weiter
es sind jetzt fünf monate
die erschöpfung um ihn zu es ist sommer
2010 in ein paar wochen beginnt einer
paula mit der schule
ob ihre mutter am ersten schultag dabei
sein wird ist ungewiss
jederzeit könnte die nachricht kommen
dass sie ins spital muss das ist
zermürbend
seit fünf monaten ist der koffer fürs
spital gepackt und dann habe ich einfach
ein paar kleider eingepackt und so lässt
sich sehr gepackt mit sachen die noch
nicht angebrochen sind aber das ist
eigentlich das was sie sagen ebenso
spiele neuer bürste zahnbürste das muss
alles neu was er genau und das muss man
dann nachher auch wenn ich aus bekannten
was komme meine mutter muss man sehr
kritisieren dass mit dem mit date also
mit dem putzen zu haus auch es muss hier
ja alles sauber gemacht werden es müssen
alle schränke ausgewaschen werden
das müssen die wände herunter
teppiche müssen raus und die gardinen
müssen gewaschen werden und die
getragene kleidung muss noch gewaschen
werden also jacken etc was man so hat
das immunsystem von transplantierten
wird anfangs praktisch lahmgelegt sonst
würde der körper das neue organ nicht
annehmen
die infektionsgefahr ist entsprechend
hoch die hygienemaßnahmen sehr streng
ein paar tage später schreibt nicola
heiser es ist soweit heute nacht bekomme
ich ein neues herz sie gibt die
erlaubnis die operation zu filmen
um ein uhr morgens nehmen die ärzte das
kranke herz von nicola heraus
zwei biografien kreuzen sich wenige
stunden zuvor ist ein mensch gestorben
es war sein wille dass seine organe
weitergegeben werden sein herz wird im
körper von nicola häuser weiter schlagen
um fünf uhr morgens beginnt das herz
erneut zuschlagen
[Musik]
während der ersten zeit geht es nicola
heißer nicht gut
die herzschwäche hat auch die übrigen
organe angegriffen
sie hat viel flüssigkeit im körper
eingelagert die nieren versagen
es kommt so einer abstoßung die ärzte
können es mit medikamenten behandeln
aber die richtige dosierung der
medikamente braucht zeit
nicola heiser braucht zeit
[Musik]
über ein jahr hat sich michaela manser
mit der frage beschäftigt ob sie eine
lungentransplantation will oder nicht
sie hat sich dafür entschieden
zuerst aber nimmt michael amann sah noch
dass matura diplom in empfang
[Applaus]
erst vier monate später setzt sie ihre
entscheidung um michaela manser geht für
zwei wochen ins zürcher unispital bevor
sie auf die warteliste kann wird sie
buchstäblich auf herz und nieren geprüft
zum ersten mal trifft sie dem mann der
sie operieren wird walter weder ist
klinikdirektor der thoraxchirurgie an
zürcher unispital so dass zur
transplantation rühmt den chemiker
transportation für die meisten recht
sicher machen dass wir gut stehen was
man nicht störe ist der verlauf nach
phase durchlaufe
durchschnittlich ist es so dass doch ca
95 prozent von der patient aktuell
bleiben wobei die zahler wert laufend
verbessert
ludwig liefert schweiz und 4 tage werden
mehr möglichkeit habe dies käufer wieder
ins freie
[Musik]
märz 2011 michaela manser ist auf der
warteliste bis es zu einer
transplantation kommt wird sie das tun
was sie bis jetzt immer getan hat
möglichst normal weiterleben
[Musik]
seit der herztransplantation von nicola
häuser sind bald vier wochen vergangen
es geht ihr wieder gut endlich es gab
tage da dachte sie dass wir es nicht
schafft nun wird sie nach vorne zu
blicken
ich freue mich darauf wie verrückt jetzt
auf dieses diesen nächsten abschnitt in
meinem leben und bin sehr dankbar dass
ich das alles erleben darf also und dass
ich auch so viel glück hat das ist alles
so gut gegangen ist und das ist wirklich
ja ja es ist irgendwie ja weil es ist
einfach so toll also es unfassbar für
mich ja es gibt die ganze zeit so
außerdem freudentränen sr glücklich also
das ist wirklich komme ich da drauf
einfach mal wieder loszulaufen irgendwie
in die stadt zu gehen und nicht immer
denken schaffe ich das noch mit
einkaufstüten haut zu kommen oder nicht
oder lasse ich das lieber oder einfach
mal laufen wieder rennen habe ich schon
ewig nicht mehr gemacht ist toll da
freue ich mich richtig drauf
[Musik]
mein ding
seither sind vier monate vergangen schon
jetzt führt nicola häuser wieder ein
nahezu normales leben
am ersten schultag von ana paula war
nicola heißt zwar nicht dabei dafür ist
sie jetzt mehr denn je für ihre tochter
da meinte sorg freut nicola heißer und
für ihre tochter ana paula fox und mit
wie viel energie dass die beiden das
zweite leben gestartet sind jetzt voller
heißer schon für ihre halbjahr mit der
neue herz visier jetzt kommen wir
[Musik]
nein
s
ich freue mich sehr mona vetsch schön
sie zu sehen
doch wir haben vor allem in texas und
ist das sagen ja geht ihnen sehr gut
also hab mich jetzt wirklich sehr gut
erholt
wo massiv auf ihr hobby als letzte mal
gesehen ein täter sind zigarillos grant
das neue leben sie sich gut erholt kauf
der transplantation aber es ist immer
noch die kritische phase ist aus
halbjahr steuern wie ist das ja also das
ganze ist schon recht lange noch
gegangen dass ich wirklich also nach
zwei jahren ist es mir eigentlich erst
richtig gut gegangen oder anja das erste
halbe jahr durfte ich auch nicht in den
stall
ach was sag ich euch diese pilze und
sporen im heu und stroh das licht so
durch die luft das sehen wir alles gar
nicht und das geht bei normalen gesunden
menschen ist kein problem und wenn man
immerzu prämiert ist kann das nicht
wirklich
ebenfalls zu fall leider junge geben und
die medikamente sind so da kommt alles
mögliche was man eigentlich gar nicht
rechnet was gar nichts mit dem herz und
der transplantation an sich zu tun jedem
fall ist überhaupt nicht klar
genau das ist ein klacks sein das ist
ein bisschen damit rechnet dass sie zwar
zwei zähler hinter preis ohne ihren kurs
und ohne ihre herrschaft genau ich habe
für mich immer ganz fest daran geglaubt
dass das klappt weil ich habe immer
gesagt ich bin mit diesen direkt im
stall aufgewachsen wir haben als kleine
kinder hat sich als wir schon ponys und
ich habe gesagt ich bin das gewohnt
und das klappte
mitte märz trat glaubten
dank ihrem starken willen und
unterstützung von familien und freunde
von sprung zu sprung den galopp zu
wechseln jetzt nur noch das machen die
34 jährige trete ich zurück im kurs sie
schafft wieder mit ri zu sein und
trainiert pferd heißt er mit was er
zeige teilt ja wieder was ihr eine
zeigen ja das sind soja sind schon meine
glücksmomente und wenn ich dann auch
hart arbeiten kann mit dem feld also für
mich auch hart arbeiten kann und dann
nicht immer anhalte und denker luft mehr
und ich habe keine kraft mehr und wie
das früher war wo ich zwei runden
getrabt bin und schon wieder eine pause
braucht dass sie in der flugstunde wo
kriegen sie hände ganz gut die russin
training kantigen herrschte verstauen
sind sie brachten wieder data wo sie was
sie vorher sie sind vorderhand nein noch
nicht also das braucht einen sehr langen
aufbau und das dauert natürlich zeit ja
so wie man ich bin jetzt wirklich
letztes jahr recht viel turnier wieder
geritten auch mit den jungen pferden
es läuft gut und aber ich denke dass ich
wieder auf das niveau kommen wo ich war
gibt es noch zwei drei jahre
was für ziel hat er sein ziel erreicht
mein traum ist natürlich schon wieder
irgendwie also olympiade zu reiten das
ist ja für jeden also für mich ist das
der größte traum also große championaten
weltmeisterschaften und so weit zu
kommen und pferde auszubilden und
deshalb ein traum noch
herztransplantation die olympische
spiele für nicolai so schien wieder
alles möglich wir begleitet sie aus
inselspital bern zur jahres kontrolle
im podium zu fahren zwischen 60 und 70
zwei tage lang wird sie intensiv die
checkt es wird gemessen wie belastbar
für nickel heiß als profisportlerin
wichtiger wert das resultat der nikolai
siry leistungsfähigkeit weit über dem
durchschnitt sogar im vergleich mit
gesunden personen wie ich das jetzt
versehen wenn sie das auf sendung gehöre
ja bin ich froh ich hätte jetzt
vielleicht sogar gedacht wäre idee ich
ihn besser gewesen weil es mir leichter
gefallen ist aber es ist halt eben
glaube ich auch immer tagesform abhängig
dann fühlt sich halt nicht jeden tag
gleich gut und ich hoffe ich sehe mich
rein natürlicher so grund der
transplantation wenn wenn es mir nicht
gut geht was woran es jetzt liegen
könnte und wenn ich dann nicht weiß
warum mache ich mir schon ein bisschen
sorgen und wenn ich dann zu untersuchen
gehe dann denke ich mir ja auf lesen
alles gut aber in der regel ist es gut
[Musik]
der tochter pauli betreut
vier jahre nach der transplantation ist
wahrscheinlichkeit von abstoße kriegen
der körper das neue organ angewiesen
es gibt patienten patienten mit 34 30
für das sogar noch länger nach der 20
auch wenn man muss natürlich auch wäre
wie ich sage dass die erwartete die
lebenserwartung von einem spenderherz
schon etwas weniger wie schwer weil man
zeigen derzeit real ist für sie die
gedanken im label dass sie wissen
wahrscheinlich hätte das herz wenn ich
nicht ganz so lange wenn sie ihre eigene
hätte also ehrlich gesagt ich denke gar
nicht so dass ich jetzt denke es hängt
jetzt nicht so lang ich habe zehn jahre
vorher
noch mehr unter dieser herzinsuffizienz
gelitten und da war für mich immer ich
weiß gar nicht wie nächstes jahr
aussieht bei mir und da hatte ich
überhaupt keine zukunft und jetzt habe
ich also ja ich sagen wie professor
tisch und sagt es kann uns alle
erwischen oder und ich denke irgendwie
so gar nicht ich denke mal das geht
jetzt alles gut und mir geht es auch gut
und sehr positiver mann eingestellt ist
desto besser geht und ich bin total
optimistisch dass das dass ich alt genug
wert so dass ich in mein leben erfüllt
habe so genau
[Musik]
mit spürt jedes geschenk
sie weiß das ist kurz leben selbst ein
tisch nicola heißt die eine frau um ihr
vor vier jahren dok film begleitet hat
die zweite ist michaela manser durch
schweizer rechtssystem fibrose liegt vor
vier jahren ihre als ob sie sich auf der
warteliste gestanden für neue junge
hätte man auf ein spenderorgan gefunden
der weg zu den michaela manser für die
pädagogische hochschule zürich
[Musik]
so aber gar nicht gut an aber jetzt wird
auch in das semester staudt der dt ha ja
was gemeinschaft portion junge
transportiert das sind ganz klar machen
alle mit dir machen
michaela manser hat lang ihre jungen
leser war das trio anfang 2014 ist es
endlich so maxi zu dem zeitpunkt ist
ihre bühne gegangen
hüttig sie 420 und jahrhundert habe
anschließen es bilde zur oberstufe
lehrerin
im moment so lange überhaupt setzte sich
schon sie waren die erste wahl
[Musik]
und wenn du jetzt es so am lauf frisch
wie groß ist so groß dass man sie nicht
haben will
als ich einfach befreit rang laufe ohne
art strengen sie ich habe gar nicht
schmeckte da war vorher mit gaddafi
gegangen dann hätte es so viel energie
braucht zum trecker überhaupt bewältigen
daher müsse konzentrieren magnetischer
maistre über den beruf macht soviel
immer da wo man sich gar nicht so
bewusst dass ich frei juni überlege vola
fidura das verständlich so richtig durch
rufe auf stufe rasch dass es jetzt
wirklich sehr unterschiedlich ist jetzt
ist jörg rieger zahnlos und ich hatte
keine vorstellung wie es wirklich ist
aber es ist total deutschland haben
keine angst aber estate weiter dem
moment wo du dir sorgen gemacht da ist
es nicht rechtzeitig wissen wo im
november transplantation habe ich einen
vertrag und ich möchte ihm so gut dass
so erholt hat und dann habe ich mir aber
leid wie lange das 6
und wirklich ein grund zur rechten zeit
doch eine wirklich auf das die bald
kommt jetzt nach der transplantation
muss michaela manser alle zwei bis drei
wochen zur kontrolle ist zürcher
unispital sich immer mehr kritische
phase wird lohnen könnte abgestoßen
werde ihres immunsystems unterdrückt und
die größte gefahr für sie ist eine
infektion zu schützen
13 maske
ein hufe tests bluttat alles das ist
routine für ziemlich jeder mann soll
aber erst vor einer woche endlich
besuchen untersucht reiche kunden führen
ab schließlich wird michaela den job 60
gesund gefühlt vier tage lang ist im
spital mit cortison behandelt wurde
hüther hofft sie dass wert sind denn
nimmt sie ihre moderation tablette im
gesamtes in street spiele jeden tag
während michaela manser auf ihre
testresultat wartet nun mit ihren amazon
transplantation
es ist so lange zeit die zweite
vierteljahr und es gab wirklich
hintergrund und was davon wirklich
jetzt ist es also das ganze leben
abgeben
das schon schwieriger moment
nach etwas anderem spender der familie
sich
und da machte christian bänden leitender
arzt für die klinik für pneumologie
bespricht mit dem michaela manser
testergebnis gut dann gehen wir zusammen
die laborwerte von heute durch und die
sind alle gut gelungen
der verlauf bitte michaela manser ist
gut wer wie viele junge cf patienten
statistik seit das fünf jahr nach der
transplantation von zehn patienten 7 bis
der zweite transplantation wäre
lediglich möglich aber das problem ist
dass es viel zu wenig organspender gibt
wer darüber über organknappheit buch 112
menschen wie sie nicht rechtzeitig oder
gar nicht worum ich die
spendebereitschaft die schweiz die
vorreiter ist noch da
ja das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen
die schweiz ist jetzt nicht europaweit
auf dem allerletzten platz bezüglich der
organspende aber schon im unteren
drittel das muss man sagen andere länder
sind trotz gleicher spenden regelung zum
beispiel spanien deutlich besser sicher
doppelt so gut in anführungsstrichen wie
das in der schweiz der fall ist das ist
immer sehr sehr unterschiedlich wie
menschen darauf reagieren hängt von
regionen ab von kulturellen hintergrund
es ist sicher so dass wir in einer zeit
leben in einer gesellschaft leben wo das
thema tod ja nicht unbedingt jeden tag
auf unserem auf unser programm steht ob
ein patient jetzt oder ein mensch jetzt
letztendlich ein spender werden möchte
wenn es ihn irgendwann mal treffen würde
das sind dinge die die kümmert man sich
einfach nicht als relativ simpel so ein
spender aus diesem stellungsfehler und
den hat mir diese schau verdrängen aber
auch die bequemlichkeit für die sich
eine kombination aus beidem
[Musik]
die zahl ist ja auch wieder gestiegen
wird michaela manser ist zieht vom
wandel zum glück vorbei
[Musik]
in neue leber vor der nikolaus kommt im
moment zu den schönsten im reitstall sei
mit ihrer tochter ana paula und gott die
fünfte cross ana paula ihre
leidenschaftliche liebe wurde
sie nimmt am turnier teil und die beste
trainerin wo sie sich am wünsche
habt ihr gut ihr beiden ganz toll wie
ist die idee zieht man sich nur in
details wo sieht eine
herztransplantation kann also ich wollte
so wie vergessen weil es war ziemlich
schwierig für mich so ich war in der
zeit in der schule auch ziemlich
aggressiv und so also ich hab ich weiß
ich wütend also ich war jetzt nicht
irgendwie ich habe letztlich geschlagen
aber ich war immer ziemlich unfreundlich
und sehr weil ich hatte da halt die
ganze ein bisschen angst
ja denn die kooperation ist schon kurz
nach us-recht gar wo bist du wie heißt
das motto
also ich kenne einfach bei meinem vater
gewesen dann war ich trank nach der
herztransplantation und hat es und
schnupfen und so und dann durfte ich
auch nicht zu meiner mutter weil ich
eben schnupfen unter hat und das ja ich
hab halt schon oft geweint und so und
jetzt wie ich es jetzt ein jetzt denke
ich eigentlich nicht mehr so viel dran
[Musik]
mein ziel ist sich ja mal dass ich dir
noch mehr aufbauen kann das was ich
jetzt habe und dass ich da eine gute
basis hat zum arbeiten und gesund bleibt
das ist eigentlich das allerhöchste für
[Musik]
michaela hallo bitte michaela manser hat
sich nochmal ein bisschen tritt im
letzten sommer ist sie zweimal sogar mit
ihrem freund simon michel die beide sind
schon vor der transplantation des borg
sie aber sieht er ist iris leibe
farbiger wurde michaela manser hat viel
mehr energie und sie können jetzt das
machen wofür die meisten anderen
verständlich wandere russland verreisen
oder einfach auswärts größe vor der
operation ich esse führt michaela quark
sie sieht einfach nicht mögen
und du bist eben dass sie operiert
worden ist und was für gedanken war
einmal eine küsst wenn sie jetzt sitzt
drach und wenn sie sich operiert wird
und den ersten für friedrich
er weiß es ist wichtig dass alles gut
gelaufen ist das erweckte planen da
jetzt eigentlich miteinander aktiv als
das was vorher plant wo du eine
planfeststellung ja vorher einmal mehr
funktionen ein horizont und den dax und
das nachholen
in diesem monat und jetzt jetzt ist noch
da und services ist schön und meiner
kapläne suite wieder große lotto mit
denkt über transplantation uns und wir
haben
ich habe hier also für mich sehe mir
klar sie und du machst studium und du du
schaffst nach und verständlich ist das
nicht
[Musik]
die dankbarkeit die beiden frauen kennen
gelernt
[Musik]
für nicola heißer und michaela manser
ich jeden tag wertvoll wie in ich
bewusst bleiben
das geschenk
[Musik]
innere woche machen muss auf zürcher
nach norbu sherpa der hauptfiguren
empfehlen sherpas die wahren helden am
everest überraschend in der schweiz
hätten nick führt andrea trat in mein
leben und ich verdanke es ihr dass sie
den mut aufbrachte einen schritt weiter
zu gehen
es ist es perfekt mit ihrer partnerin
andrea zimmermann will den ort dem
frühling auf der feststiege wo sie sich
auf den weg machen uns nicht ahnen dass
es schwer sei aber bald alles verändert
[Musik]